welcome to Google Club drawing board
where we doodle our way through the
cloud today's topic what is compute
engine simply put it refers to
customizable virtual machines running in
Google cloud you can select the right
machine for your needs from predefined
or custom machine types predefined
machines come with general-purpose
combinations of CPU and memory but if
those don't meet your needs then you can
choose the custom machine types which
allow the selection of exact number of
CPU and amount of memory you need for
your workloads there are three different
machine type families general-purpose
computer optimized and memory optimized
general purpose machines are best suited
for general workloads like web servers
and databases if you're not sure which
family you should choose just choose
general purpose instances it is
recommended to use compute optimized
machines for compute intensive
applications such as high performance
computing gaming electronic design
automation and single threaded apps if
you have memory intensive workloads such
as in-memory databases sed HANA or
real-time analytics use memory optimized
instances and you can add graphical
processing units to accelerate
computationally intensive workloads like
machine learning or medical analysis now
how do you use compute engine well it's
easy just select the type of machine and
where you want it and the instance gets
created for your use in that specific
location there are some features of
compute engine that make it an awesome
choice it allows for live migration so
your app can keep running during
maintenance mode without interruptions
it provides sizing recommendations for
example if you are using a bigger
instance for a workload that can run on
a smaller instance then you can save
cost using these recommendations and for
your container workloads
it supports deployment of containers now
what
does it cost to use compute engine it is
simple you paint for what you use but
you can say it cost by taking advantage
of some discounts sustained you savings
are automatic discounts applied for
running instances for a significant
portion of the month if you know your
usage upfront you can take advantage of
committed use discounts which can lead
up to 57% savings without any upfront
cost and by using short-lived
preemptable instances you can save up to
80% these are great for batch jobs and
fault tolerant workloads along with lots
of other use cases like running websites
and databases on compute engine you can
also use it to migrate your existing
systems into Google cloud or even run
Windows applications by bringing your
own licenses or using the included
licensed images to noodle more on
compute engine check out quartered
google.com slash compute